le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
l'eau est une ressource vitale sa
protection et sa gestion représente un
enjeu majeur la réunion est l'un des
départements où la consommation est la
plus élevée avec une population en
constante augmentation
il est donc urgent de réveiller les
consciences et d'établir une politique
responsable et efficace l'office de
l'eau est un organisme rattaché au
conseil départemental de la gestion à la
prévention ce service public accompagne
tous les acteurs concernés
[Musique]
on peut fermer long parce que si on
laisse l'eau coulait provoque on
s'abonne pas fait le look cool et qui ne
sert à rien et donc à 50 litres d'eau
pour une douche 10 litres pour une
chasse loïc est médiateur à l'office de
l'eau sa mission sensibiliser la
population pour optimiser l'usagé de
leurs bleus faut qu'on ait conscience
que l'os est une ressource essentielle
surtout à la réunion on est un petit
territoire les ressources en eau sont
limités on a on a des besoins qui
augmentent avec la population la
population et des ressources qui vont
rester identique ce jour là dans ce
lotissement de sainte rose loïc fait
plusieurs démonstrations résident donc
maintenant regarder l'aspect de l'eau
voyez maintenant on voit plus mon doigt
à travers
mitigeur mélangeur le médiateur présente
plusieurs dispositifs simples pour faire
baisser la facture et surtout économiser
le précieux liquide au niveau des
toilettes la chasse à double commande
qui est souvent installés en fait déjà
chez les ch et les personnes mais qui ne
savent pas forcément à quoi ça sert donc
on esprit bien que tu mets une petite
chasse une grande chasse ces petits
gestes quotidiens ne sont pas encore
adopté par tous on a fait comment
zoé fait moins dépensé radiant
les toilettes qui m'ont impressionné je
ne savais pas qu'il existait de vote en
fonction
la réunion est un des départements où
l'on consomme le plus d'eau en moyenne
200 litres par jour et par personne
pérenniser cette ressource naturelle
passe aussi par des mesures régulières
dans les milieux aquatiques de lille la
russie combien avant
serge et dominique sont en mission de
terrain dans le lit de la rivière saint
denis tous les mois ces agents de
l'office de l'eau viennent vérifier le
débit de la rivière alors qu'il ya des
banques russes
sexy matin l'équipe en profite pour
relever l'un des nombreux appareils de
mesure disséminées sur l'île et ça
n'apparaît que ça fonctionne en continu
c'est-à-dire les mesures à la hauteur
d'eau la température d'eau et
et nous envoie sa part jassem au bureau
l'office de l'eau et d'un établissement
public rattaché au département il a été
créé en 2003 et joue un rôle de
coordination pour tous les acteurs
locaux liés à l'eau c'est l'étude et le
suivi la ressource en eau des milieux
aquatiques et que les usages de tous sa
deuxième mission c'est lé conseil
l'assistance technique la
sensibilisation
les renseignements l'information qu'on
apprend donc à tout type de public trois
émissions c'est la programmation des
actions et des travaux les ressources
financières de l'office c'est
essentiellement au travers la facture
d'eau 70% donc des ressources
financières viennent de leur facture
d'eau aujourd'hui l'état des ressources
est plutôt bon la principale difficulté
reste les intempéries à la saison des
pluies quand on prend de l'eau dans une
ravine ou dans une rivière le set au
bien se charger de particules avec des
microbes avec des choses qui arrivent
donc à ce moment là il faut à traiter
c'est tout mais sinon le reste de
l'année pour les rivières aller en
général de très bonne qualité l'enjeu
pour les spécialistes anticiper les
problématiques à venir à l'heure
actuelle cinq pour cent des abonnés au
réseau de distribution reçoivent une eau
non potable
un chiffre qui risque d'augmenter dans
les années à venir nous allons avoir à
peu près un million d'habitants entre
2025 et 2030 avec trois défis à relever
une démographie dynamique le
développement urbain et le réchauffement
climatique
il faut savoir que la directive
européenne impose dès 2017 2010 8 de
délivrer une eau dite potable au sens
européen du terme donc nos principes a
louangé actuellement c'est d'aider les
collectivités à monter les stations de
potabilisation est ce que on estime les
besoins financiers pour la protéger
risation sont 250 millions d'euros dans
les années qui viennent
[Musique]
l'office de l'eau est un établissement
public local qui a trois grandes
missions l'étude et le suivi des
ressources la programmation et le
financement d'actions de travaux le
conseil et l'assistance technique aux
maîtres d'ouvragé pour la période 2016
2021 le besoin en financement dans le
domaine de l'eau et de 352 millions
d'euros 20 % de ses besoins sont assurés
par le département via l'office de l'eau
pour plus de renseignements vous pouvez
vous rendre sur le site www.info
reunion.fr
[Musique]
m